Oh, let's go next to, um, why don't we go
next to Cesar from San Antonio.
Caesar.
What's going on?
Okay.
Hello?
Hey, how are you all?
Can you hear me?
Yeah, I can.
Yeah.
Um, yeah, my question I want to say is what
is the deal with all these I insane pseudo
intellectual in act with groups such as, for
example, anti vaccine movement in cells, mic
towel flap or series and all these crazy groups
that are just not only increasing but online,
but also entering the main stream public of
a pin.
Well, so let's see.
I mean, what are they increasing?
I don't know if they're increasing or if they're
just louder, you know, like for example, I
don't know that Donald Trump has created more
white nationalists, but he's definitely emboldened
them so that we hear more from them.
So I don't like what, what evidence do you
have that these beliefs are actually increasing?
I'm not saying you're wrong, I'm just asking
are they actually increasing or are we just
hearing from them more?
Okay.
Yeah, I think we're just hearing more from
them because a few years ago, I didn't even
know that that's some of the stuff even existed.
I mean, I didn't know that that even existed
or slot earth
people hold on season.
I mean, certainly if even if someone's not
called an insole, you knew there were people
who weren't able to find others to have sex
with.
Right.
Like you knew that that was a thing.
Not Everybody is able to do that.
Yeah,
I know that's an easy sell.
I mean, okay, so now it has a name, but those
people have been around for a long time.
Yeah.
But the late people are, like, for example,
with themselves, I didn't know that people
actually went on crazy shootings or hurt people
just because they can get lazy.
Okay.
Well now we're starting to get into some more
specific dynamics, but certainly the idea
of if not for being unable to get laid as
you laid out, we know that people for a very
long time, uh, are driven to commit acts of
violence because they are sort of disaffected
by society in a general way.
Right.
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about doing
this.
Just kind of strange that somebody would do
that.
Okay.
Well, I mean you may find it's main, I don't
know that it's new.
I mean here, here's what I think the more
important question, which is the pseudo intellectual
ism that you talked about.
That's really the danger for me because there's
always been a group of people that just isn't
really interested in learning or in knowing
stuff and it's just sort of like, okay, that's
always going to be around.
But the danger to me is the pseudo intellectuals
who think that when they read these kind of
bluff political pop books like a book by,
uh, you know, Laura Ingram or Tucker Carlson
or whatever, and they think that they're educated
in some way and then are like, well equipped
to participate in discussions about the future
of the United States and what policies should
be.
I think that that's the danger that people
that think that they are informed and in reality
they're not, they're not seriously informed
about issues and then they vote and they have
an impact.
That's really the concern for me.
Okay.
Yeah, I know.
But like for example, in a, what else?
Talking about the Anti Vaccine Movement.
Seriously.
People need to learn to vaccinate already
because we don't need the measles or, or even
small pox coming back.
I mean,
yeah, I mean, I mean seriously this idea that
vaccines cause autism is nonsense.
Yeah.
It had been literally debunked and the guy
who pushed it was a lost his medical license.
Cesar basically agree with you.
A really appreciate the call.
Thank you.
All right, take care.
Great to hear from Caesar.